سرطان الثدي هو ثاني أكثر
أنواع السرطانات شيوعًا بين النساء في الولايات
المتحدة وثاني سبب رئيسي
لوفيات السرطان بين النساء بشكل
عام كل عام ، يتم تشخيص حوالي 245 ألف حالة جديدة
لدى النساء في الولايات المتحدة و 2200
حالة عند الرجال بينما -
يبلغ معدل البقاء على قيد الحياة حوالي 90
بالمائة تقريبًا ما يقرب من 41000 امرأة
ويموت ما يقرب من 500 رجل منه كل
عام. سرطان الثدي هو مرض
تنمو فيه الخلايا في الثدي خارج نطاق
السيطرة بينما يمكن أن يبدأ في
مناطق مختلفة من
الثدي ويمكنه أيضًا أن ينتشر و  ينتشر إلى
أجزاء أخرى من الجسم النوعان الأكثر
شيوعًا من سرطان الثدي هما
سرطان الأقنية الغازية ، حيث
تنمو الخلايا السرطانية خارج القنوات
إلى أجزاء أخرى من الثدي.
في حين أن بعض الناس قد
يعانون من أعراض ، فإن الكثير منهم لن يفعلوا ،
ولهذا يتفق الخبراء على أن
فحوصات سرطان الثدي المنتظمة والتشخيص المبكر
أمران أساسيان  ial للدقيقة الصحية اليوم
أنا ميريديث وود